Was macht man da in der Schule?
- Ich weiss es nicht.
Spielen!
Spielen.
Und kochen?
- (Alle, laut) Nein!
Nein, Quatsch mit Sauce.
Diese vier Kinder
leben auf der Rigi auf 1'500 m ü.M.
In einem Jahr
kommen sie in die Schule.
D.h., sie müssten täglich
mit der Bahn ins Tal fahren.
* Sanfte Zithermusik *
Seit 19 Jahren gibt es nämlich
keine Schule mehr auf der Rigi.
2018 beschliessen junge Eltern
auf dem Berg, das zu ändern.
Die Initiative kommt vom Hotelierpaar
des Kräuterhotels Edelweiss.
Gabriella und ihr Mann Gregor
träumen davon,
dass ihre beiden Kinder
die ersten Schuljahre
ohne Druck eines herkömmlichen
Schulbetriebes erleben dürfen.
Deswegen möchten sie wieder
eine Gesamtschule eröffnen.
Ihr Küchenchef Benjamin Just
und seine Frau Lili
würden ihre zwei Kinder auch gerne
auf dem Berg zur Schule schicken.
Das Konzept einer kleinen Naturschule
überzeugt sie sofort.
Deswegen haben sich die beiden Paare
zusammengetan.
Aus meiner Schulzeit
habe ich mitgenommen,
dass es für Kinder oder fürs Lernen
allgemein hilfreich ist -
auch wenn ich in der Küche
mit meinen Mitarbeitern lerne -
dass man daran beteiligt ist.
Und dass das in einer grossen Gruppe
nicht gut funktionieren kann.
Aus unserem Sozialkörper merken wir,
dass sich immer welche hervortun,
ganz automatisch,
und sich viele zurückziehen.
Das geht an der Potenzialentfaltung
vorbei.
Gabriella Egger
ist in diesem Hotel aufgewachsen
und besuchte die damals
noch bestehende Gesamtschule.
Sie übernahm das Hotel
von ihren Eltern
und möchte ihren Kindern
ein freies Lernen ermöglichen,
so wie sie es erlebt hat:
Für mich ist es
eine emotionale Angelegenheit.
Ich ging sechs Jahre
hier oben zur Schule.
Ich kann nur von sehr vielen
schönen Momenten erzählen.
Rigischule heisst für mich:
vor dem Schulhaus übernachten
und Sternbilder betrachten
und dazu die griechische Mythologie
in Märchenform erzählt bekommen.
Rigischule heisst für mich auch:
"Heute ist schönes Wetter,
holt eure Skis!"
Das sind Dinge,
die ich meinen Kindern auch wünsche:
Solche Erinnerungen an ihre
Schulzeit mitnehmen zu können.
Im August 2018
informieren die Initianten erstmals
die Öffentlichkeit auf der Rigi.
Ihr Plan ist ehrgeizig.
In einem Jahr schon
wollen sie die Schule eröffnen.
Ausser den Kindern und viel Enthu-
siasmus fehlt noch ziemlich alles:
ein Schulzimmer, Schulmaterial,
Geld für Löhne und eine Lehrperson.
Und eine Bewilligung des Kantons.
Ein Schulberater,
der auch auf der Rigi wohnt,
unterstützt die Elterngruppe
ehrenamtlich:
Mein Anliegen
ist eine solide Grundlage:
dass wir uns
nach dem Lehrplan orientieren.
Wir werden ein Konzept ausarbeiten.
Wir haben bereits einen Entwurf
des Konzeptes aufgehängt.
Den dürft ihr euch
in aller Ruhe anschauen.
Das ist der Anfang
und wird noch ergänzt und verändert.
Ihr seht, wie wir arbeiten wollen
und was unser Ziel im Ganzen ist.
Habt ihr schon Zusagen,
z.B. von der Gemeinde, vom Kanton,
Unterstützungen, die es gibt?
Oder läuft alles auf privater Basis?
Wir sind daran, Leute anzufragen.
Wir haben
noch ca. 20'000 in der Kasse
vom Verein Rigi-Kinder,
die wir nutzen wollen.
Die Aufgabe des nächsten Jahres
wird sein: Stiftungen anzufragen.
Ehemalige Schülerinnen und Schüler
leben immer noch auf der Rigi.
Die Gesamtschule
haben sie in guter Erinnerung.
Man musste lernen,
sich zu konzentrieren,
sich nur auf das Eigene
zu fokussieren.
Dabei aber trotzdem
bei den anderen zuzuhören.
Gelehrt wurde Selbstverantwortung
und sich auf etwas zu konzentrieren,
was gerade wichtig ist.
Die Idylle ist natürlich
spätestens beim Übertritt
in die Oberstufe vorbei.
In der Anschlussklasse im Tal
gibt es viel mehr Kinder.
Es war wirklich happig:
Zweimal 24 Kinder in einer Klasse.
Wenn der Lehrer etwas fragte,
dachten alle,
der andere solle die Antwort geben.
Man fühlte sich nicht angesprochen.
Diese Mentalität,
der andere soll es sagen,
fand ich total daneben und blöd.
Ich kannte nichts anderes.
Wenn der Lehrer etwas fragte,
musste man sich Gedanken machen,
man musste eine Antwort geben.
Das hatten die anderen nicht drauf.
Rigi Kaltbad hat rund
110 Einwohnerinnen und Einwohner.
Viele Häuser gehören Feriengästen.
Bis in die 1960er-Jahre
standen mitten im Dorf ein Grandhotel
und das Hotel Bellevue.
Dort wurden bereits ab 1902
Kinder unterrichtet -
auf Privatinitiative
der Hoteliers Dahinden.
Weil die Familie selber
zehn Kinder hatte.
* Sanfte Zithermusik *
Eine ihrer Enkelinnen,
die heute 90-jährige Ruth Reinecke,
besuchte 1935 die erste
öffentliche Schule auf der Rigi:
Es gab eine Schule.
Beim Bahnhof gab es ein altes Haus,
wo die Remisen standen.
Dort, wo die Züge
der alten Scheidegg-Bahn standen.
Dort kam die Schule hin.
Früher wohnten die Gäste im Sommer
mehrere Wochen in den Hotels
und schickten ihre Kinder
auch in die Rigischule.
Es gab Zeiten, da besuchten 36 Kinder
die Gesamtschule.
Zeitweise
gab es sogar zwei Schulhäuser.
Eines für die Kinder
auf der Luzerner Seite,
eines für die Kinder
auf der Schwyzer Seite.
* Fröhliche Flötenmusik *
Im Winter kämpften sich
die Bauernkinder oft stundenlang
durch die Schneemassen,
um rechtzeitig in der Schule zu sein.
Die Lehrerin sah, wie sie kamen
und als Erstes gleich die Hand auf
das Pult legten und einschliefen.
Sie legte sie in die Betten
und sagte: "Schlaft erst!"
Was soll ich sagen?
Wir hatten immer wieder
Klassenzusammenkunft.
Es ist aus allen
etwas Rechtes geworden.
Offenbar brachte die Schule etwas.
Ein jähes Ende der idyllischen
und prosperierenden Zeit
brachte 1961
der Brand des Grandhotels.
Der Tourismus brach ein.
Schwindende Arbeitsplätze zwangen die
Familien, vom Berg ins Tal zu ziehen.
* Bedrückende Zithermusik *
Die Klassen schrumpften, und so
wurde die Rigischule geschlossen.
Seither können die Kinder auf zwei
Seiten ins Tal zur Schule fahren.
Auf der Schwyzer Seite der Rigi
finanziert die Schulgemeinde Goldau
mit jährlich 63'000 Fr.
einen Schülerzug.
An Werktagen immer morgens um 7 Uhr,
ausser in den Schulferien.
Derzeit für zwei Kinder
von einem Bauernhof.
Im Sommer steigen eine Station weiter
unten noch zwei Älplerkinder dazu.
Alle anderen mit gültigem Ticket
dürfen den Zug auch benutzen.
* Gemächliche Glocken-Klopf-Musik *
Der Vater der Älplerkinder
auf der Schwyzer Seite der Rigi
ist als Bauernsohn hier aufgewachsen.
Eine Schule auf dem Berg
hätte ihm damals schon gepasst:
Es ist schade,
dass die Schule geschlossen
und nicht mehr weitergeführt wurde.
Sonst hätte ich auch hier
zur Schule gehen können.
Inzwischen hat er mit seiner Frau
selber zehn Kinder.
Ein paar sind schon ausgeflogen.
Jetzt haben wir noch zwei,
die in die Primarschule gehen.
Nächstes Jahr kommt noch eines
in den Kindergarten.
Es könnte sein, dass sie in Zukunft
während der Alpzeit
ihre Kinder auch
in die Rigischule schicken werden.
Aber noch
gibt es die Schule ja nicht.
Auf der Luzerner Seite fährt die Bahn
von Vitznau auf die Rigi.
Dort arbeitet Marion Fercher.
Danke.
- Schönen Tag.
Seit zwei Jahren lebt sie
mit Mann und Kind auf Rigi Kaltbad,
und sie wollen ihre Tochter Linda
unbedingt in die Rigischule schicken.
Uns ist es wichtig,
dass der Schulweg gut ist,
dass sie in unserer Nähe ist.
Für mich ist es auch einfacher,
zur Arbeit zu gehen.
Ich arbeite am Berg.
Ich bin froh, wenn sie nachmittags
nach Hause kommen kann
und ich auch zu Hause bin.
Ein anderer wichtiger Punkt
ist auch,
wenn andere Familien hierherziehen,
damit auch sie ihre Kinder
in die Schule schicken können.
* Sanfte Musik *
Im Oktober
ist aber immer noch nicht klar,
ob es überhaupt klappen wird
mit der Schule.
Unterstützung
erhoffen sich die Initianten
von der katholischen Kirche.
Ihr gehört dieses Haus,
die alte Kaplanai.
Hier ging Gabriella Egger zur Schule.
Der Raum steht meistens leer,
und darum ist Gabriella
mit ihrem Küchenchef Beni unterwegs
zu einem Gespräch
mit Kirchenvertretern.
Für mich ist nicht entscheidend,
ob es dieser Raum
oder ein anderer wird.
Aber es ist natürlich
eine tolle Lage.
Es ist auch auf schöne Art
vorbelastet.
Der Raum bietet alles,
was man braucht:
sanitäre Anlagen, Garderobe,
Vorraum, grosse Wiese draussen.
Es ist direkt
an der Talstation des Skilifts.
Zudem ist es in der Nähe des Waldes.
Und ... - Unsere Kinder
können mit Schlitten ...
... und Ski zur Schule.
Auf die Antwort werden sie
bis in den Winter warten müssen.
(Frau) Seid ihr da?
- (Kinder) Ja!
Skifahren lernen die Rigikinder
fast gleichzeitig mit dem Gehen.
Falls es mit der Schule auf der Rigi
klappen würde,
wäre es wieder wie bei Gabriella
vor rund 40 Jahren:
Der beste Schulweg überhaupt.
Ich konnte morgens
auf die Ski stehen,
bis ins Schulhaus fahren.
Um nach Hause zu gehen,
nahm ich den Skilift.
(Mann) Laufen lassen! Mach mal!
Schneller! Hopp, hopp!
Ihr altes Schulzimmer wäre also auch
für die Kinder heute ideal gelegen.
Der Winter ist lang auf der Rigi.
Im Januar 2019, an der GV des
Trägervereins der geplanten Schule,
beschliessen Gabriella
und ihre Mitstreiter u.a.,
dass der Elternbeitrag
pro Kind und Monat 500 Fr. sein soll.
Und die Antwort der
katholischen Kirche ist endlich da:
Wir haben eine Zusage für den Raum,
allerdings mit Bedingungen,
die für uns sehr schwierig sind.
Die Miete ist relativ hoch.
- Was heisst das?
150 Fr. pro Tag. Für drei Tage
macht das fast 2'000 Fr. pro Monat.
Das belastet unser Budget
enorm stark,
für einen Raum, in dem wir
nicht einmal Erstmieter sind.
Wir bräuchten einen Ausweichraum,
falls die katholische Kirche
den Raum selber braucht.
Dafür 2'000 Fr. zu bezahlen ...
Wir teilen unser Schulzimmer
sehr gerne,
aber wir möchten die Freiheit haben,
Bilder, Landkarten,
Kinderzeichnungen aufzuhängen.
Wir möchten abends nicht alles
zusammenräumen und wieder gehen.
Das ist nicht das,
was wir uns vorstellen.
Das bedeutet, in Sachen Schulzimmer
fangen sie wieder von vorne an.
Was sie nicht davon abhält,
trotzdem eine Lehrperson zu suchen.
Wir haben die Stelle ausgeschrieben.
Sie ist auf der Onlineplattform
für Lehrpersonen erschienen.
Es sind einige Bewerbungen
eingegangen.
Ich habe mit zwei bis drei Personen
bereits Kontakt aufgenommen.
Jetzt schauen wir weiter.
- Wie sieht es aus? Ist jemand dabei?
Ich bin sehr zuversichtlich.
Die angefragten Personen
sind sehr interessiert
und sind sich bewusst,
worum es geht.
Jeden Mittwochnachmittag
findet man die Rigikinder
in der Waldspielgruppe.
Auch bei klirrender Kälte.
Haben alle einen Platz?
- Ja!
Der Bär und der Vogel
sind gute Freunde.
Jeden Tag gingen der Bär
und der Vogel in den Wald.
Ich sehe ihn!
Sie sind bereits
eine eingeschworene Gruppe.
Wenn es klappt, werden sie im Sommer
in der neuen Schule
die ersten vier Schülerinnen
und Schüler sein.
* Kuhglockenbimmeln *
Der Schnee ist längst geschmolzen.
Das Gebimmel der Kuhglocken:
das untrügliche Zeichen
des beginnenden Sommers.
Es dauert nur noch ein paar Wochen
bis zum Schulbeginn.
Wie jeden Tag fährt das
Direktionspaar des Hotels Kaltbad
mit der Bahn auf die autofreie Rigi.
Ihnen käme es sehr entgegen,
wenn ihre Kinder hier ihre ersten
Schuljahre verbringen könnten:
Das Schöne ist,
es ist eine Ganztagesschule.
Sie sind vom Morgen
bis am Nachmittag in der Schule,
kochen und essen zusammen
Mittagessen.
So sind wir flexibler
für die Arbeit.
Das Zweite ist: Ich finde es toll,
dass sie draussen sind.
Sie lernen in der Natur.
Es geht so schnell.
In der Schule sind sie immer drin
und müssen lernen.
Das freie Lernen
finde ich sehr schön.
Die Gruppengrösse von vier Personen
kann auf lange Sicht
schwierig werden,
weil die Gefahr besteht,
dass es beendet wird.
Wir hoffen, dass aber noch
das ein oder andere Schulkind
aus Weggis oder Vitznau Eltern hat,
die den Vorteil der Natur und allem
genauso sehen.
Das könnte natürlich
eine Gefahr sein,
aber für die nächsten Jahre
ist es schon mal gesichert.
Im Sommer zeigt sich
ein Silberstreifen am Horizont.
Die Schule hat eine Lehrerin.
Und zwar eine, die sich darauf freut,
mit den Kindern
möglichst viel draussen zu sein.
Natürlich
werden die Behörden kontrollieren,
ob sie die Lernziele erfüllt.
Wir gehen nach den Zielen
des Lehrplans 21.
Diese werde ich
draussen erfüllen müssen.
Wie soll das gehen?
- Draussen kann man viel erreichen.
Wir haben an vier Tagen Unterricht.
Mittwoch, Donnerstag,
Freitag und Samstag.
Am Samstag einfach nur am Morgen.
Das haben wir
an die Gastronomie hier angepasst.
Ein Schulzimmer
haben sie nicht gefunden,
aber eine kreative Alternative,
die sie in kurzer Zeit
mit Crowdfundig finanzieren konnten:
Hier sieht man
mein zukünftiges Schulzimmer.
Die Jurte ist ausgesteckt.
Das ist der ganze Jurtenplatz,
den wir haben.
Ist das im Winter beheizbar?
Die Jurte ist im Winter
zum Glück beheizbar.
Das wird nötig sein.
Lernen sie auf den Knien schreiben?
Sie haben ja kein Pult.
Ja, die Kinder werden auch Lesen,
Schreiben und Rechnen lernen.
Vieles kann man draussen machen.
Wir werden kleine Tische
aus Holz machen.
Darauf oder auf Unterlagen
kann man schreiben.
Mit kreativem Denken
geht das problemlos.
Ein kleines Detail haben
die Initianten dabei nicht bedacht.
Eine Jurte darf
man nicht einfach so aufstellen:
Im Moment warten wir am dringendsten
auf eine Baubewilligung
der Gemeinde Weggis,
damit wir endlich unsere Jurte
aufbauen können.
Eigentlich sind schon alle
organisiert, die mithelfen werden,
um die Jurte aufzubauen.
Ja, das ist im Moment das Einzige,
was uns noch aufhält.
Die Schule ist Gregors
und Gabriellas Herzensprojekt.
Im Dorf äussert man sich
grundsätzlich positiv.
Es gibt schon kritische Stimmen.
Teils auch Schüler,
die oben zur Schule gingen
und es nicht nur als glückliche Zeit
in Erinnerung
oder einen schweren Übergang hatten,
als sie unten
eingeschult worden sind.
Leute, die sich fragen:
"Was soll das, braucht es das?"
"Sie können doch nach Weggis
oder Vitznau."
Oft sind das aber Stimmen, die wir
nicht direkt zu hören bekommen,
sondern über andere.
Die Schule auf die Beine zu stellen
funktionierte nur
dank grosser Unterstützung.
Alles war aufwendiger als erwartet -
wie so oft bei Pionierarbeit.
Der Küchenchef ist überzeugt,
diese Art von Schule
macht die Kinder teamfähiger,
und ihr Schulprojekt
entspricht einem Trend:
Für mich ist es eine schöne Sache,
das Urvertrauen meiner Kinder
und das vieler anderer zu stärken.
Ähm, ja ...
Dass es sich mit der Zeit streut.
Man merkt ja auch insgesamt
die ganze Entwicklung.
Auch in der Schweiz.
Wie viele solche kleine Projekte
in der Naturpädagogik
viel grösser geschrieben werden
als z.B. vor zehn Jahren.
* Sanfte Musik *
Und am 14. August 2019
ist es tatsächlich soweit:
Nach 19 Jahren gehen auf der Rigi
wieder Kinder zur Schule.
Heute ist es endlich so weit:
Wir haben es geschafft,
wir haben gestern die Bewilligung
für die Rigischule bekommen.
Es war eine Riesenarbeit,
und heute geht es endlich los.
Am ersten Schultag sind die Eltern
wohl angespannter als die Kinder.
Dass die Bewilligung vom Kanton
tatsächlich erst einen Tag
vor Schulbeginn gekommen ist,
das ist den Kindern egal.
Ihr Interesse
gilt v.a. dem Schulzimmer:
Du kannst auswählen,
welchen Hocker du möchtest.
Weisst du schon welchen? Vielleicht
haben auch zwei an einem Platz.
Janosch ...
Ein Schulzimmer haben sie jetzt.
Aber spannender
ist es definitiv draussen.
* Feiner, hohen Glöckchenklang *
Ich begrüsse euch ganz herzlich
in der Rigischule.
Jetzt sind gleich die Kühe gekommen,
schaut mal!
* Sanfte Klänge *
Wir kennen unsere Namen bereits.
Ihr kennt auch mich bereits.
Ich möchte von euch wissen,
welches euer Lieblingstier ist.
Änneli, was ist dein Lieblingstier?